>>> CONSPIRACY SPREADER ALEX
JONES FILED FOR PERSONAL
BANKRUPTCY TODAY.
THE FILING COULD POTENTIALLY
DELAY THE NEARLY $1.5 BILLION
TWO STATE COURTS HAVE AWARDED
FAMILIES AND OTHERS WHO SUED
JONES FOR DEFAMATION ON FALSE
CLAIMS ABOUT THE SANDY HOOK
MASSACRE, THE VICTIMS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
LATER THIS MONTH IT'S GOING TO
MARK TEN YEARS SINCE THE MASS
SHOOTING THAT KILLED 26 PEOPLE
INCLUDING 20 CHILDREN.
IT'S ABOUT HOW LONG THESE FAMILY
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN WAITING TO
HOLD MR. JONES TO ACCOUNT.
WITHIN HOURS OF THE ATTACK JONES
WAS SPINNING LIES ABOUT THE
SHOOTING BEING A FALSE FLAG
EVENT.
HIDCULING THEM, LYING ABOUT
THEM.
IN OCTOBER I SPOKE WITH SOME
SANDY HOOK PARENTS AND THE
DAUGHTER OF THE PRINCIPAL WHO
WAS MURDERED WHO TOLD US THESE
VERDICTS WERE IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THEY SEND A STRONG MESSAGE NOT
JUST TO JONES BUT, QUOTE, FOR
ANYONE WHO HAS A SICK ASPIRATION
TO BE LIKE HIM.
I'M JOINED NOW BY "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" ELIZABETH WILLIAMSON
WHO'S REPORTED EXTENSIVELY ON
THE TRAGEDY AND ITS AFTERMATH
AND LAWSUITS.
HER BOOK IS EXTRAORDINARY.
ALSO JOINING US IS CNN SENIOR
LEGAL ANALYST ELI HONING, FORMER
ASSISTANT U.S. ATTORNEY.
I KNOW YOU LOOKED THROUGH JONES'
BANKRUPTCY FILING.
WHAT STOOD OUT TO YOU?
>> SO WHAT HE SAID IN HIS ASSETS
SECTION OF TODAY'S FILING,
ANDERSON, WILL SURELY BE
CHALLENGED BY THE FAMILIES.
HE SAYS HE HAS ASSETS OF BETWEEN
1 AND $10 MILLION.
THE FAMILIES MAINTAIN HE HAS
MUCH MORE THAN THAT, AND IN
FACT, HE HAS SIPHONED $60
MILLION OUT OF THE BUSINESS
POSSIBLY INTO HIS -- INTO THE
COFFERS OF FAMILY AND HIMSELF.
SO THAT'S WHAT THEY ALLEGE.
THEY'LL DEFINITELY BE
QUESTIONING WHAT THE FILING WAS
TODAY AND TRYING TO FIND THAT
MONEY.
>> DOES FILING FOR BANKRUPTCY,
CAN HE HIDE ALL THESE ASSETS?
>> HE'S CERTAINLY TRYING BUT I
DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
SUCCEED.
IT MIGHT EVEN BACKFIRE,
ANDERSON.
AND HERE'S WHY.
A PERSON CANNOT DECLARE
BANKRUPTCY AND HAVE ALL HIS
DEBTS MIRACULOUSLY VANISH.
NOT THESE DEBTS, NOT WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A JUDGMENT THE
TRIAL VERDICT HERE THAT INVOLVES
AN INTENTIONAL WRONG, AND HERE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DEFAMATION.
THAT'S WHAT ALEX JONES WAS FOUND
LIABLE FOR.
THAT IS INTENTIONAL.
THE FAMILIES, WHAT THIS DOES,
THOUGH, IT COMPLICATES THE TASK
FOR THEM.
NOW THEY HAVE TO BASICALLY GET
ONLINE WITH OTHER CREDITORS,
OTHER PEOPLE OWED MONEY.
AND WHAT ALEX JONES IS TRYING TO
DO IS SORT OF SHRINK THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY AVAILABLE TO THEM.
HE'S TAKING MONEY, MOVING IT ALL
OVER.
HE'S TRYING TO CREATE THESE
RIDICULOUS DEBTS THAT ELIZABETH
REPORTS ON WHERE HE ESSENTIALLY
OWES HIMSELF AND HIS PARENTS $50
MILLION IN ORDER TO SORT OF JUMP
THAT LINE AHEAD OF THE PARENTS.
BUT WHAT I THINK THIS IS GOING
TO RESULT IN IS THE PARENTS AND
THEIR LAWYERS HAVE EVERY
INCENTIVE TO TRACK DOWN THIS
MONEY AND MAKE SURE HE PAYS IT.
>> DURING THE FIRST DEFAMATION
TRIAL, ELIZABETH, IN TEXAS,
THERE WAS A FORENSIC ECONOMIST
WHO TESTIFIED JONES HAD MOVED
AROUND A LOT OF HIS MONEY.
I MEAN, HOW MUCH DO YOU KNOW
ABOUT THAT?
HOW MUCH HAD THEIR LAWYERS
LEARNED ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, AS ELIE SAID, YOU KNOW,
HE HAS CLAIMED HE'S INDEBTED TO
THE TUNE OF $54 MILLION TO AN
LLC OF A COMPANY THAT IS
CONTROLLED BY HIMSELF AND HIS
PARENTS.
SO IN A WAY IT'S A KIND OF SHELL
GAME.
HE IS WORTH BETWEEN 130 AND $270
MILLION, ACCORDING TO THAT
FORENSIC ECONOMISTS.
>> WOW.
WAIT, ALEX JONES IS WORTH WHAT,
200 AND WHAT?
>> BETWEEN 130 AND $270 MILLION.
>> WOW.
>> SO FOR HIM TO SAY HE HAS
ASSETS OF BETWEEN 1 AND $10
MILLION IS JUST SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE ABSOLUTELY CHALLENGED BY
THE FAMILIES AND THEIR LAWYERS.
YEAH, AND HE EARNS REVENUES OF
UP TO $70 MILLION A YEAR.
SO IT'S A LOT OF MONEY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE, AND HE'S
TRYING TO MAKE IT AS ELIE SAID
LOOK LIKE A LITTLE BIT.
THE FAMILIES CHALLENGE EVEN THE
NOTION THAT HE IS BANKRUPT
BECAUSE OF THESE DEBTS TO
ESSENTIALLY HIMSELF AND THE
MONEY THAT HE HAS BEEN MOVING
OUT OF THE COMPANY INTO THINGS
LIKE REAL ESTATE AND RELATED
VENTURES AND THINGS THAT THE
FAMILIES AND REALLY NOBODY AT
THIS MOMENT FULLY UNDERSTAND.
>> ELIE, IT'S EXTRAORDINARY TO
ME THIS GUY WHO PLAYS THIS TOUGH
GUY ON HIS, YOU KNOW, BROADCASTS
AND ACTS LIKE HE'S THIS BIG
TOUGH GUY WITH THESE SECURITY
GUARDS WHO ARE ALL DRESSED
IDENTICALLY AND I GUESS THEY
PLAN THEIR WARDROBES THE NIGHT
BEFORE IS HIDING BEHIND PARENTS.
>> IT'S PREPOSTEROUS AND
CERTAINLY DOESN'T MEASURE UP
WITH THE BOMBAST AND NONSENSE
ALEX JONES IS KNOWN FOR.
AND WHAT THIS DOES IS IT SHOULD
MOTIVATE THE PARENTS TO --
>> IT COSTS A LOT OF MONEY TO
TRACK DOWN --
>> IT DOES.
THAT'S WHY YOU HIRE LAWYERS AND
IT'S COSTLY AND INVESTIGATORS TO
TRY TO FIND THIS.
BANKRUPTCY IS AN EDGED SWORD
BECAUSE ON ONE HAND IT CAN
PROTECT YOU BUT ALSO EXPOSE YOU
TO SCRUTINY.
IF THIS GETS INTO ACTUAL
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDINGS THE
PARENTS WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
THROUGH THEIR LAWYERS TO
QUESTION ALEX JONES.
HE HAS TO ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS
UNDER OATH.
AND HERE'S THE THING IF HE LIES,
IF HE COMMITS FRAUD, PROSECUTORS
CAN GET INVOLVED.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
PROSECUTORS WHO SPECIALIZE IN
BANKRUPTCY FRAUD, AND THAT'S WHY
LONG-TERM THIS COULD BE
DANGEROUS FOR ALEX JONES.
>> ELIZABETH, I'M WONDERING
ALMOST TEN YEARS SINCE SANDY
HOOK, I'M WONDERING WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ARE ESPECIALLY AS THESE
PARENTS, YOU KNOW, HAVE BEEN ON
THIS NIGHTMARE QUEST FOR -- FOR
TRUTH WHILE THEY ARE GRIEVING.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
I MEAN AS I SAID, YOU KNOW, WITH
YOU PREVIOUSLY, ANDERSON, THIS
IS A SIGNIFICANT SECONDARY
TRAUMA THAT THEY'VE SUFFERED.
FOR FOUR YEARS THEY HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING WITH ALEX JONES, BUT
FOR YEARS BEFORE THAT THEY'VE
BEEN TRYING TO FIGHT BACK
AGAINST PEOPLE WHO NOT ONLY --
NOT ONLY AGAINST THE WORST DAY
OF THEIR LIVES BUT PEOPLE WHO
DENY THAT IT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
SO THIS HAS TAUGHT THEM NOTHING
IF NOT PATIENCE AND FORTITUDE.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO SEE AS THEY GO FORWARD
AND THEY USE AND HOPE THAT THE
BANKRUPTCY COURTS DO THEIR JOBS
IN SHEDDING LIGHT, USING THIS
FILING TODAY AND THE PREVIOUS
FILINGS FOR JONES' COMPANY TO
TRY AND EXPOSE, YOU KNOW, WHERE
THESE ASSETS ARE, WHAT THEY
ACTUALLY A